das schönste aller farbe lesen
für konrad kessler war als real der
körperbau durchaus plausibel
mit rufen und hörnern gut aber warum
sollte das nicht möglich sein
und so nahm er es auf das einhorn in
sein allumfassendes tier lexikon konrad
kessler universalgelehrter
wissenschaftler von weltrang die
historia anime um ein lexikon von allem
was kreucht und fleucht auf der erde
einzigartig in seinem bilderreichtum und
sein bedeutendstes werk 1516 wird er
geboren
der küster sohn in zürich sobald der
reformatorische geist durch die engen
gassen wehen wird geßner studiert
medizin und wird statt arzt von zürich
hier hat ulrich zwingli inzwischen die
reformierte hohe schule im grossmünster
gegründet für praktische philosophie und
naturkunde denn die natur
sie ist für die reformierten die zweite
offenbarung gottes geßner lehrt an der
hohen schule studiert die antike denker
will die natur in ihrer vollständigkeit
und schönheit erklärt eine tulpe so was
hat die welt noch nicht gesehen
geßner publiziert sie als erster
überhaupt als einer der ersten
beschreibt er auch die organe von
pflanzen zeichnet sie zeigt
detailversessen wie pflanzen
funktionieren
auch so kann man gottes schöpfung logo
die suche nach der alles durchdringenden
wahrheit sie treibt ihn um den
workaholic in seiner wohnung an der
franken gasse sammelt beobachtet und
seziert er
maulwürfe sind blind liest er bei
aristoteles glaubt es aber nicht fängt
unzählige maulwürfe und seziert sie
und siehe da sie haben so arbeitet er
er überprüft das alte wissen lässt es
aber auch stehen vom salamander zeit
geßner zwei bilder auch das widerlegte
falsche wissen schaffen zeigen wie
fakten sich entwickeln es ist eine
hektische zeit die blütezeit des
buchdrucks die zahl der publikationen
explodiert informationsflut wie heute
und gestern es nicht eher sind kunst
unermüdlich sammelt ordnet er wissen
systematisch wie kein zweiter zuvor baut
er seine kapitel auf reisen
keine chance für den staat arzt
sein reiches informantennetz schickt ihm
berichte aus der neuen welt geschichten
von nie zuvor gesehenen dinge ein
expeditionsteam schickt geßner einen
tukan schnabel genauestens untersucht er
ihn und findet keine nasenlöcher wie der
vogel atmet bleibt ihm ein rätsel
geßner der daheimgebliebene abenteurer
er ist der erste schweizer der
meerschweinchen besitzt so spannend
seine zeit ist sie hat ihre tücken
wahre nachrichten mischen sich mit
märchen von wundersamen wesen das ist
wohl was falsch
das herauszufinden bleibt kästners
lebensaufgabe vieles versteht ihr noch
nicht die regel ganz entsteht für ihn
aus der enten muschel und der löwe
dieses geschmeidige tier hat laut
gestern einen einzigen starren knochen
anstatt einer beweglichen
halswirbelsäule ihrem gehört zur
wissenschaft
in diesem sinne ist konrad kessler der
prototyp des modernen forschers das
einhorn existierte für ihn weil es
keinen gegenbeweis gab ein vorgehen das
die wissenschaft bis heute praktiziert
denn auch sie hat immer noch so manche
einhörner